new evidence suggests that there were
warning signs about Nicholas Cruz and
they were overlooked or maybe they were
ignored his Instagram page shows photos
of weapons including one of him with
guns and knives a law enforcement source
tells CBS News the local sheriff's
office was told two years ago that an
Instagram post using Cruz's name said he
was going to shoot his school the
sheriff tells our Miami station that's
WFOR
he was unaware of that Jericka Duncan is
at Cruz's home in parkland where the FBI
continues to search for clues there
Jericka good morning good morning Cruz
moved into this home behind me with a
friend back in November after his mother
died now he did live at a home nearby
and police were reportedly called there
39 times beginning in 2010 because of
Cruz for calls ranging from domestic
disturbance to abuse they were signs
that people knew he had troubling
behavior and they noticed it my sister
had texted me and said it was Nicholas
Cruz and I said oh my god I know him
Sarah Lau he says she knew Nicholas Cruz
from his job at the Dollar Tree store he
had this weird disposition about himself
he followed me on Instagram and I saw
all of the pictures of his guns he had a
picture of his gun up to his face Wow he
says she regrets not doing more as soon
as I heard what happened immediately my
mind was I should have done something I
could have prevented this
people who knew Cruz say he spoke about
his guns and hurting animals
shelby's Fino lived two doors down from
Cruz I saw him with the gun aiming at
their chickens President Trump tweeted
on Thursday neighbors and classmates
knew he was a big problem must always
report such instances to authorities
again and again I'll probably never
forget that name been denied at
Mississippi bail bondsmen says he
contacted the FBI in September when he
noticed a comment on one of his youtube
videos that troubled him it said I'm
going to be a professional school
shooter posted under the username
Nicolas Cruz the FBI visited the night
the next day anybody that makes a public
statement like that definitely needs to
be investigated
but on Thursday the FBI said the post
was a dead end because it lacks specific
information about the time location and
identity of the person who posted it no
additional information was found to
positively identify the person who
posted this comment after the Columbine
shooting in 1999 the US Secret Service
and Education Department published a
handbook detailing how to prevent school
attacks but in that study it did not it
was not able to actually place a trait
or behavior on a student to determine if
they were in fact planning a school
shooting but obviously in the case of
Nicholas Cruz a lot of people believed
he had the potential and now we have
social media Jericka Duncan thank you